todo marruecos y gran parte del mundo
lleva días conmocionado con el caso del
niño rayán hoy en los servicios de
rescate han de marruecos han sacado el
cuerpo de este niño sin vida del pozo al
que cayó el pasado martes en la
localidad de iu grama en chefchauen en
el norte del país cayó en este pozo a 32
metros de profundidad el niño tenía 5
años y como decimos ha sido encontrado
sin vida los servicios de emergencias
han trasladado su cuerpo al hospital y
hasta el momento se desconocen más
detalles para intentar sacar al niño han
trabajado durante la cantidad de días
pues muchos cuerpos especiales del país
para poderlos sacar tuvieron que cavar
primero un túnel paralelo en vertical al
pozo donde estaba el niño y después para
poder acceder a la posición y excavar en
otro túnel horizontal los trabajos han
sido de la dificultad pues dadas las
condiciones del té y también se han
demorado más tiempo del deseado porque
ha habido diferentes derrumbes como
decimos al finalmente hoy los de
servicios de rescate han sacado a este
niño de 5 años del pozo al que cayó el
pasado martes a 32 metros de profundidad
y desgraciadamente lo han sacado sin
vida